et pour en parler justement on est avec
benoît martin secrétaire de l'union
départementale cgt paris bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin vous avez pris
connaissance de cette lettre
les lignes de cette missive envoyée par
edouard philippe qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé et surtout est ce que vous
faites confiance au chef du gouvernement
pas du tout confiance il se moque de
nous non déjà lu cette lettre tout alors
effectivement il nous parle de
démocratie sociale de démocratie
parlementaire de justice sociale etc
mais il se moque de nous lie à un
passage en force qui est absolument
inadmissible on va remobiliser dans les
prochains jours mais déjà hier soir on a
réussi à faire une première
manifestation devant l'assemblée
nationale qui n'était pas prévu qu'ils
étaient spontanées mais ç'a eu lieu dans
plusieurs grandes villes de france
également
et donc on ne va pas laisser faire il
n'y a aucune c'est un déni de démocratie
et c'est un déni de justice sociale et
le texte qu'ils vont faire passer sous
forme de 49,3 et complètement incohérent
et injuste
mais est ce que c'est une surprise
réellement le le recours aux 49 sera de
la part du gouvernement parce qu'on
approche quand même d'une échéance
électorale et avec le gouvernement avait
pour objectif de faire passer ce projet
de loi avant cette échéance une surprise
la date d'hier oui nous a un peu surpris
d'autant plus qu'il y avait un conseil
des ministres hier martin hier matin
pendant consacré aux cons à virus et
donc on est on est ressortis avec 1,49
froid sur la réforme des retraites
c'était un peu surprenant la date nous
surprend mais le 49 3 en lui-même ne
nous surprend pas mais il faut bien voir
que le travail en commission avant
qu'ils aient ce travail en séance
plénière au parlement n'a pas eu lieu
finalement face ça n'a pas abouti
et puis là il n'y a que huit articles
sur 45 qui ont été traités par les
députés donc ne pas aller jusqu'au bout
c'est vraiment un déni de démocratie
donc pas surpris que le 49-3 soit
dégainer comme on dit
mais c'est une violence politique qui
lui dénonçant alors les fins des cadres
pro m
vous promettez en tout cas de vous
mobiliser peut-être la semaine prochaine
il ya quand même un souci on parlait du
coronavirus il ya eu cette réunion il
hier et l'interdiction de rassembler de
se rassembler en masse à des revenus de
5000 personnes ce n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui
ça veut dire quoi concrètement est ce
que véritablement les mobilisations vont
être possibles pour contester le passage
de cette réforme des retraites enfin à
oui là on entre dans une nouvelle phase
clairement à partir d'aujourd'hui de
demain
il ya on a des réunions syndicales dès
aujourd'hui et d'autres demain pour
accélérer bousculer les agendas
syndicaux qui était prévu il ya une
première phase qui étaient là le rapport
delevoye et c est là la mobilisation en
vue du 5 décembre après on a eu une
deuxième phase qui était une grande
mobilisation sociale entre le 5 décembre
jusqu'à la fin février à peu près après
mars a été moins mobilisateur mais bon
c'était le temps également politiques
parlementaires etc
là on a également dans une période
d'élections de mi cipal bien entendu
voilà et donc
bon donc mais elle est là on est deux
voilà on est entré maintenant le 1er
mars et donc comment la virus l'épidémie
en tout cas ça risque de porter
préjudice aux éventuelles mobilisations
vous avez prévu il faut décorrélée les
questions faut s'occuper de santé
publique d'un côté il faut s'occuper des
retraites
de l'autre parallèlement mais nous nous
autres organisations syndicales nous
allons continuer à mobiliser et s'il
devait y avoir des menaces sont nos
manifestations publiques en raison du
fait que nous serons plus de 5000 ce qui
sera le cas bien de bien entendu ça ça
ne passera pas on va pas laisser faire
c'est la re mobilisation sociale a eu
lieu dès hier soir les spectacles prévus
par l'opéra de paris hier à bastille et
à l'opéra garnier n'ont pas eu lieu
parce que les salariés de l'opéra se
sont remis en grève dès hier soir
et donc voilà on est dans une phase de
re mobilisation extrêmement importante
manne mars mars c'est dieu de la guerre
vous savez le savez la semaine prochaine
ça va être la guerre sociale en mars
vous annoncez une guerre sociale la
semaine prochaine quelle mobilisation
qu'elle jouera selon vous votre avis
alors le jour où la halle et la motion
de censure sera présenté à l'assemblée
nationale alors j'attends que la date
soit stabilisée mais
voilà ce sera un jour forcément de
mobilisation extrêmement importante et
la suite parce que si ce projet de
réforme parce puisque l usage du 49-3
comment est ce que vous allez mener
aujourd'hui le combat mobiliser toutes
les professions pour contester et est ce
que c'est possible de voir le
gouvernement faire marche arrière
aujourd'hui eh bien il le faudra bien
c'est ce que l'on vise nous on est dans
le champ syndical
donc on va faire de la mobilisation
syndicale par les grèves les
manifestations qui ont plus qu on va
pouvoir faire il ya le champ politique
aussi certains groupes parlementaires
certains partis politiques demandent un
référendum et on sait très bien quand
même que les plus des deux tiers des
français non seulement ne veulent pas de
cette réforme mais veulent que le
gouvernement le retire retire cette
réforme est donc c'est ce qu'on sait ce
que l'on vise merci beaucoup
benoît martin je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire de l'union départementale cgt
parrish merci à vous merci